acteur sculptées dans le bois un
dispositif qui donne à entendre les sons
de l'élevage un travail sur les tenues
les outils les couleurs du monde paysan
chacun et chacune des quatorze artistes
s'approprient le thème du monde agricole
à sa manière selon ses sensibilités j'ai
passé du temps à
faire des visites d'ateliers à la
rencontre d'artistes qui sont concernés
par les problématiques agricoles parce
que filles et fils de paysan ou petite
fille ou petit fils de paysan et qui
avait envie de parler finalement de
cette histoire de cette mémoire et de
ses réalités kako et stéphane caine qui
sont des artistes paysans réunionnais
ils rendent compte en photos de leur
réappropriation de 6 hectares de terres
familiales dont ils veulent bannir la
canne à sucre c'est un passé lourd
la canne à sucre est une forme une
hérésie écologique économique et même
sociale c'est un prolongement au système
colonial c'est des photos qui s'appelle
teufeurs ont les aptitudes et est fleur
qui veut dire bonjour en créole en fait
et en fait on s'est mis torse nu dans
des champs de manioc qui pousse très
bien la réunion et c'est une symbolique
de
partie d'un ensemble une double cote
déployer figé sur un mur un mélange de
vues aériennes et de l'aisne le travail
de morgane danes l'air est issu d'une
résidence chez un couple d'éleveurs
ovins le travail il est vraiment passé
par le fait de de travailler avec eux le
travail et de rentrer dans leur
quotidien de travail de passer par le
faire
et dans émerger des oeuvres ce qui a
donné cette forme là en fait
qui est donc des châssis qui sont
inspirés de la forme des clôtures
l'exposition agir dans son milieu et
présenté au transpalette à bourges
jusqu'au 16 janvier prochain